california is shrinking california
has grown consistently since
the gold rush since 1850
and last year for the first time ever
california shrunk more people left
california
then came into california born in
california
so if the population is shrinking here
i am actually part of that diaspora of
people fleeing
what does that mean for the golden state
means that they are in big trouble
gamora by the sea
is going down in flames i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from larry who says
i remember the day i was so excited when
i heard michael had chosen my comment
then he pronounced my name wrong and now
my brothers still make fun of me i still
listen though
that's very kind larry
but you the problem with your comment is
you didn't
tell me how to pronounce it in the
comments so i'm perhaps i've corrected
it inadvertently
but i may well be mispronouncing your
name again
i hope i've gotten it right i'm not
gonna hedge i'm just gonna stick with
larry
i hope that larry is the right name
otherwise you're gonna have to add
another comment
we'll see if that one gets picked too
it's really sometimes people don't think
right when they don't sleep well if you
want to sleep well you got to go check
out helix
everyone is unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size
sleepers if you are looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't even have to
go to a mattress store you don't ever
have to go to a mattress store ever
again
go to helixsleep.com knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
and you will get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they will even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you absolutely
will love it it's so simple and look i
don't want
something made for somebody else i want
something made for me feels great head
on over helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
knowles what is that address helix
sleep.com slash knowles for up to 200
off and two free pillows california's
population fell by more than 182
000 last year and we here at the daily
wire account for about i don't know 120
of them
not 120 000 but 120 people because we're
out you know just like rogan is out just
like
elon musk is out just like everybody's
out everybody is fleeing
cali because the weather's still great
but everything else is going
going down you've got crime through the
roof
you've got homelessness through the roof
even though the mayor of la for instance
passed a gigantic bond a few years ago
to take care of homelessness what
happened it got worse and worse and
worse
you've got shops boarded up you've got
the most draconian lockdowns
in in the country and you've got
confiscatory taxes so yeah
you're gone there's only so far you can
push us california before we're out i
was on my friend alex michaelson's show
on fox in la
just a couple of weeks ago and i pointed
out i said california's shrinking he
said hey hey michael
look california is still growing it's
just that the rate of growth has
decreased
and i let him have it i said maybe he
knows something that i don't know but i
thought
you know maybe immigration for instance
is is taking off at a higher rate than i
was
expecting but turns out i was completely
right california actually
is shrinking and i wonder why i wonder
why i see headlines like this
about the los angeles district attorney
george gascon one of the most
if not the most radical prosecutor
in the united states he's a prosecutor
but his whole
aim is to like criminals off the hook
so a couple of criminals he left off the
hook are
a couple that killed and tortured a 10
year old boy
and the 10 year old boy was the son of
the mother killer
this is as heinous as it possibly gets
absolute there is no
doubt that these people should face
capital punishment it would be a mercy
to them it would be good for society
it would more directly satisfy justice
and it would be a mercy to them because
one hopes they could face
the reality of the moral order and get
their act together right it would be
rehabilitative for them
heather maxine baron 31 and her
boyfriend
karim ernesto leyva 35 charged in the
2018 death of anthony avalos baron's son
because the death penalty is on the
table they could now face
a maximum of life in prison without the
possibility of parole
if they are convicted is that is that
justice you know when you hear about the
criminal justice reformers and
we you know our incarceration system is
modern-day slavery and it's so unjust
and we need to spring the criminals out
of the clink by the way
there are republicans who have adopted
this ridiculous talking point
frankly it infected the trump
administration to some degree
and you know how much i love trump but
even he caved into a little bit of this
let the criminals out of jail mania
when you hear about that and then you
hear that
these psychopaths heather baron and her
boyfriend kareem leyva
killed this woman's and tortured this
woman's 10 year old son
does that make you want to spring
criminals from the clink
no it makes you want to ratchet up the
punishments not even for
revenge right i don't even know these
people
but for justice because we know it's an
injustice if these people get off the
hook
la's d.a george gascon says no we need
to think of poor heather baron
and poor kareem leyva you know society
made them
kill and torture her 10 year old son it
was
it was someone else's fault it wasn't
their fault it would be wrong to punish
them
no wonder california is shrinking you
know that
nussolini over there the patrick bateman
american psycho governor that they've
got in that state
he is facing a recall and the recall is
a little bit ridiculous because
there are some ordinary candidates
something of kevin falconer former mayor
of
of san diego i'm thinking of john cox
who
who's run before and caitlyn jenner
formerly bruce greatest athlete in the
world
you know very impressive fella all
running and you think this is kind of a
clown show now this is turning into a
reality tv circus and newsome may well
survive well
newsom seems at least a little bit
nervous because gavin newsom
totally failed governor one of the two
worst
in the country on covid and otherwise
incompetent when we're not talking about
crisis situations
he is announcing the largest tax rebate
in american history now consider this
one of the reasons that the daily wire
and others you know rogan or musk or
whoever
left california is because the taxes are
so ridiculous
taxes all state tax already 13 then
they're going to raise it to 16 that's
crazy 16
versus you move to tennessee there's
zero state income tax
that's a no-brainer i think you can only
push me so far folks
but now new some completely changing his
tune saying he wants the largest tax
rebate in american history
according to the la times the proposal
to deliver eight billion dollars in new
cash payments to millions of
californians
is part of a 100 billion economic
stimulus plan made possible in part
by a budget that's uh faced a windfall
of tax revenues
windfall of tax revenues yeah because he
jacked taxes up on everybody
so now he's got everybody's money and
he's going to give a little bit back to
them
newsom is also proposing a 5 billion
dollar plan to double rental
assistance to get 100 of back rent paid
for those who have fallen behind
along with as much as 2 billion dollars
in direct payments
to pay down utility bills that are
overdue so what does this mean this
means that gavin newsom
knows that he's in trouble knows that
his policies have failed and so he's
trying to reverse them
in the short term to survive the recall
so he's saying yeah we're gonna you know
we're gonna do um
we're gonna give away all the money to
people all the money we took from people
we're gonna give
some of it away so that you forget what
a terrible governor i am
what's shocking to me is not that
democrats would buy votes they've been
doing it for a long time and republicans
try to buy votes occasionally too
though not nearly enough i guess
democrats are cleaning their clock in
that department
but what's so surprising to me is even
in this insane race
where you've got candidates who are not
polling that well falconer and cox and
even jenner and jenner is such a an
eccentric personality who
probably would not be able to win even
in that race
newsom is afraid newsome is worried
about the possibility of losing his job
because it reminds us of something that
is an eternal truth in politics
never say never never say never remember
do you remember 2015
donald trump is running for president
comes down the escalator and the gold
and the mexicans are rapists and all
this sort of thing
and people say there is no way this
guy's not going to win nothing
never trump never trump and then what
did we have
we had never say never trump and never
say never
because the guy got elected could this
happen with
caitlyn jenner could this happen with
someone else even you know cox or or or
falconer
i suppose it could new sim knows that
too is it likely probably not but could
it happen
absolutely so this is why the left is
now training their sights on
caitlyn sarah silverman the comedienne
is is furious at caitlyn jenner because
she says that he is
transphobic with the issue of transports
what does caitlyn jenner
well-known decathlete and guy on the
wheaties box and guy who now dresses up
like a woman
what does he know about transvestitism
and athletics
what he doesn't know anything so sarah
silverman decides to educate him
i saw caitlyn jenner saying trans girls
should not play girls sports caitlyn
you're a woman
right a trans girl
is a girl she should have the same
rights as
cis girls
if you think a trans girl what you think
a trans girl is too strong
i yes what about tall girls
as opposed to short girls what about
boys in high school who are
teeny tiny and their teammates uh have
already hit puberty and are shaving
why don't you just have co-ed sports
divided by weight or height
yeah that's the difference this is so
dumb they are legislating this
without one single example of how this
plays out
this is not worrying about girls sports
uh believe me not i think
there are better ways to worry about
girl sports
this is not worrying about this is not
what that is this is not worrying this
is not concern for girls sports it's
transphobia full stop
okay virtually everything sarah
silverman just said is wrong
and is demonstrably false the
there is no example of this sports issue
being a problem for girls yes there is
there's a very famous case working its
way up the courts right now
represented by the alliance defending
freedom because guess what happens when
the boy's playing the girls sports
the boys virtually every time win so
there certainly is a case
trans women are women no they're not
caitlyn jenner you're a woman no she's
not
trans women should have the same rights
as women well they have equality under
the law but men and women are different
so they're treated differently okay
but she does say something that is
useful and true she says this is not
about girl sports
and she's totally right this is not
about girl sports i don't care about
girl sports
i've i've never watched girls sports
maybe if the olympics is on in the
background
i guess i have seen some girls sport
otherwise
i have never watched i've very rarely
watched men's sports
i have not watched women's sports i i
care in the sense that it's so unfair
that these girls who
run in track to try to get scholarships
and awards
lose them and don't get the scholarships
and don't get the awards
because some dude is faster and bigger
and stronger but
generally speaking i don't care about
girl sports what i care about is human
nature
what i care about is the relationship of
my society
and my politics to reality because the
left wants to divorce those things from
reality
and i am pleading i'm i'm clawing with
my
fingernails i'm saying no let's stick a
little bit almost on reality no and then
we fall
off of the abyss just like california is
about to fall off
of the united states and sink into the
pacific ocean
you know when you when you feel like
you're just being taken advantage of
then you gotta go check out rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and
do-it-yourselfers so if you're a
do-it-yourselfer that's cool if you're a
pro like me
you get the same price why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts
why would you subject yourself to the
humiliation of going into the store
and then they ask you you know what was
your honda the xgct7 i don't know man
it's like gray
it's gray and i bought it a couple years
ago do you have the part and then they
don't have the part they go online
they charge you way more money head on
over skip that middle man go to
rockauto.com reliably low prices
all the parts that you will ever need
head on to rockauto.com
right now check out their amazing
selection so simple even i can navigate
it
and then this is most important of all
write nulls in there how did you hear
about this box k-n-o-w-l-e-s
put that in there how did you hear about
his box so that they know that we sent
you
sarah silverman says this issue of
distinguishing between men and women and
not letting the men
play in the girls sports even if they
wear a dress and not letting the men go
into the girls bathroom if they're not
even if they're wearing a dress
it's not about the girl's sports you're
right it's not
it's totally not it's about reality
the reason that i can't call caitlyn
jenner
her the reason that i can barely call
him caitlyn i'm sort of going back and
forth on it should i just call him bruce
caitlyn is a woman's name it's not a
man's name
so if we call caitlyn caitlin aren't we
in in a much lesser degree than with the
pronouns but to some degree
aren't we mainstreaming this i don't
know i'm going back perhaps i'll go back
and forth on the on the names today
but if we call caitlyn or bruce
her my issue is not about politeness
i don't think it's polite to lie to
people so i don't i don't on that front
i don't think it's necessarily polite to
call him her
but it's not about the sports it's not
about
the way he looks it's not about the way
he talks
it is a little bit about his immigration
policy but that's a separate issue
it's just about the reality of it
i just i won't lie
about something that fundamental okay
i get it politics there's a lot of
scummy people
saying a lot of things that are only
slightly true or not true at all and
there's spinning and there's
there's dishonesty and i know that
that's true in politics i expect that of
my politicians
but you can't tell me that a man is a
woman and you can't make me
say that i just won't do it it's about
much more to that than that there is
much
much more to lose
gender dysphoria is not the only body
dysmorphic issue that we have going on
this gets to not just bruce jenner's
psychological struggles this gets not
just to
the social contagion where we erase the
distinction between men and women
this gets to a fundamental
misunderstanding
of our relationship to the physical
world that's actually what it comes down
to and so put the gender issue aside for
a second
there was a story that just came out
about the plus sized model
tess holiday which is plus size model as
a euphemism for
someone who is obese but models clothing
okay
and i guess she actually goes by the
term fat activist
a tess holliday revealed last week that
she has anorexia
and is in recovery for anorexia
morbidly obese woman has anorexia
i'm in anorexia and i'm in recovery says
holiday on twitter
i'm not ashamed to say it out loud
anymore i'm the result of a culture that
celebrates
thinness and equates that to worth
but i get to write my own narrative now
i'm finally able to care for a body that
i've punished my entire
life and i am finally free
okay where to begin i think there are
two discrete issues here
i'm i'm going to obviously there's the
absurdity that a fat person has anorexia
that's the first thing but i actually
don't think it's totally absurd you can
suffer from any number of psychological
problems even if your body doesn't match
those psychological problems
this this is this is the definition of
body dysmorphia right is that your body
doesn't match the issue
so if an anorexic is a thin person who
thinks that
he or she is fat this woman
is a an obese person who
thinks that she is too thin i guess
who thinks that she is too fat or
something
right it's just it's sort of one more
layer of dysmorphia but i actually don't
think that it's impossible i don't think
it's
any more absurd than any other body
dysmorphia so there's that issue
and then there is the issue of multiple
types of dysmorphia so what i mean by
this is
the first cultural issue i see with the
the fat
activist saying she's anorexic is
that she's basically saying i'm i
identify as a very thin person
i'm a very large person but i identify
as a very thin person
so she might say i have anorexia but
this psychological condition that she
says she has is not enfleshed in any way
it's not enacted
we live in this time right now it's a
very gnostic time
where we think that all that matters is
what's going on in our heads and it
doesn't matter what we do and it doesn't
matter what
our bodies look like and it doesn't
matter what the physical world says
if it's floating around in my head
that's fine this actually gets to one of
the issues with political correctness
political correctness replaces moral
codes
old moral codes with speech codes so
that it it replaces the the idea of
how we interact in a moral way from what
you do
to what you say there are many things
that political correctness does
all of which i discuss in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
by the way for pre-order pre-orders are
going through the roof by the way we've
got a ton
on amazon and barnes noble and all those
sites we also have the autographed first
edition copy which you can get at
premiere collectibles so
check that out uh
in the old order it's you know i might
have the best of intentions but if i
if i do something unjust if i commit a
sin
then that's what matters the road to
hell is paved with good intentions but
ultimately talk is cheap you know it
really depends on what you do
but in this culture it's all just about
what we think it's all about what we say
it's all that floats around so okay
that's the first big problem then the
other big problem is maybe this woman is
she's got anorexia okay i grant it
she has another body problem though
it's not just that she thinks she's too
fat even though she's too thin or so
she's got obviously some issues there
it's that
she overeats what she's saying is this
culture
values thinness no no this culture
exalts
fatness too doesn't it we have this
plethora of plus-sized models this woman
this woman's career is a testament to
that we have
a culture right now that celebrates
unhealthy
eating habits not just in the don't eat
enough direction but also in the eat too
much direction
we not only celebrate starvation we also
celebrate gluttony but both of those are
a problem it's actually a problem
we all struggle with lots of different
problems but
as chesterton points out heresy is not
the promotion of vice to the exclusion
of virtue
it's the promotion of one virtue to the
exclusion of all the others
so yes you've avoided the the terrible
sin of
starvation okay of you know which
goes into a lot of other issues but
you've now gone into the sin of gluttony
what you really need to do is recognize
that both of those are a problem
and try to get back there into some sort
of moderation which is a virtue
speaking of bodily comfort we have great
news coming out of the united kingdom
as the coronavirus enters its
15th month 15 days to slow the spread
became 15 months to slow the spread
we're now on month 15.
boris johnson the prime minister the
putatively conservative prime minister
who went totally squish on coronavirus
he's got great news for you pretty soon
you might be able to hug your loved ones
we're taking a step towards that moment
when we learn to live
responsibly with covid when we cease
eventually to rely on detailed
government edicts and
make our own decisions based on the best
scientific advice about how to protect
our families and those around us
so from next monday we're updating the
guidance
on close contact between friends and
family
setting out the risks for everyone to
make
their own choices wow thank you
boris wow i thank you conservative prime
minister
now brits starting monday not today so
you know hold off
starting monday they can maybe
hug their relatives using common sense
use using common sense that's how this
was covered
boris johnson now permits common sense
contact between
friends and relatives common sense it
would appear
ain't so common anymore
johnson initially had a really tough
strong approach
to the virus which was this is bad but
we're going to get through it we're not
going to totally destroy our lives and
up end our society
then he got kovid and he went totally
squish
and that's the way it's worked in so
many places
when you look into what's going on in
britain you are in many ways looking
into a crystal ball of what's going to
come to the united states
same thing in canada when you see what's
going on here
going on there rather with the total
deference to the public health experts
with the massive growth of these
government bureaucracies
with the total collapse
of that english tradition of liberty
that's
probably what's coming here folks and
we've got to be very much on guard
against that it's not just on the covet
issue
kovidge is just a lens through which to
recognize the broader political problem
because kovid demonstrates the state
established religion
of the anglosphere and the broader west
and that state established religion is
secular progressivism and the high
priests of secular progressivism
are the public health experts public
health because
the public is the political part the
health is the scientific part
and they are going to apply just as all
the progressives have done since the
dawn of
the progressive era they're going to
apply science
to our political problems and thereby
get rid of any need for political debate
you don't need to have a political
opinion anymore the scientists will tell
you
what to do and that is a fundamentally
religious point of view and it is
squeezing out the other religions
notably christianity and notably
in the united kingdom not good stuff at
all we need a manly defense against that
you know
when you want to do manly things what i
would recommend is you know you wear
sort of nice sweaters with collared
shirts and you have swarthy's skin and
high cheekbones
but if you if you want your next best
chance to be manly
you should grow a giant beard it looks
great to grow a beard
you know if you can't do these you know
if you can't like this guy will be on
them
manly men very often will grow beards
they'll grill meat they'll drink
handcrafted booze
thanks to the manliest giveaway ever
some lucky guy
will be doing those things for free how
because they could win
a stash of goods do you get it
do you get it from beard supply meat
church desert door haller brothers and
more
fabulous brands for the red-blooded
american male one lucky winner we'll get
a collection of beard oils and grooming
essentials
tools for grilling and leather care and
a 200 gift card for an outdoor menswear
shopping spree
up your man game how by winning a stash
of goods
do not delay beard supplies spring
giveaway
will be ending soon so head on over to
beardsupply.com giveaway to enter
that is beardsupply.com giveaway and
what could you win in the giveaway
why a stash of goods of course head on
over there
and good luck also check out ben's show
ben is going to be covering what's going
on in israel right now
and the left's embrace in ben's words of
jew hatred it's hard
it's hard to look around at what the
democrats you're saying and come to any
other
conclusion by the way if you own an
apple device
i have some excellent news for you all
of the daily wires latest news
commentary and analysis are now
available
on apple news we cover everything that
you're not getting anywhere else if you
want to make your news feed
infinitely better just head on over to
apple news on your device
search for the daily wire and hit the
follow button head on over to
dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
the covid lockdowns in the united
kingdom are
just the tip of the iceberg in that
country for a broader religious conflict
and you've seen this
break out into the open just this this
week
a pastor in the united kingdom who was a
chaplain at a college there
i think he was a former chaplain at
cambridge university
this chaplain was fired not only fired
but reported to a terror watch agency of
the uk government
because he gave a sermon
defending the christian view of sex
take a listen it was just so
mind-blowing
um i was thinking i'm never going to
work again
because i've been accused of being a
terrorist this is the sermon
i gave in june 2018
but remember that religious belief is
just as protected in law
as sexual orientation and no one has the
right to discriminate against you
or be abusive towards you when
ideologies compete
we should not descend into abuse we
should respect the beliefs of others the
fact that
in this day and age a sermon should be
deemed
effectively blasphemous by other people
it would just never have occurred to me
before this happened
that that could be something that would
happen in in 21st century britain which
i thought was a liberal tolerant society
so this guy obviously a thoughtful guy
you know obviously very respectful guy a
very
mild-mannered british guy it reminds me
of that scene in european vacation
where chevy chase keeps running into the
the english bicyclist on his
in his car and the bicyclist keeps
apologizing to him
he's like oh we're so sorry yes yes well
no oh yes no it's all right no no no
just a little scratch yes yeah you know
and uh so the brits very very nice
people this guy very genial and now he's
being called a terrorist
but what he doesn't understand is that
last line there at the end he said
i can't believe that in 21st century
england which i thought was a respectful
tolerant liberal society i can't believe
that
my views of christianity would be called
blasphemy
that's because this fellow doesn't seem
to understand that
liberalism is a jealous god
liberalism is a very jealous god and
uh people who practice
their religion out in the open they
tend to have a more coherent view of the
world they tend to be more grounded
there's this idea that religious people
are very superstitious
no we're actually the least
superstitious people on earth because we
know exactly what we think and we're
subjecting it to rigor
the people who pretend not to have a
religion they tend to be the kookiest
they tend to be
the most superstitious they tend to be
the most censorious
because they're not even aware of what
they're doing liberalism is a jealous
god here's what this guy did
he's at trent college which by the way
purports to have a christian ethos
and he he gave this lecture about
competing ideologies he said look
i'll give you an example we talked about
this competing ideology often you've got
the christian view of the world where
we've got you know
of human nature where man is body and
soul and you've got the transgender view
of human nature which is that
man is really just his soul and his body
is evil when his body doesn't accord
with his soul and his body has to be
mutilated to better accord with it okay
two totally different views and he says
these are competing ideologies and we
just have to be respectful of them
now he's a little nicer than i am i
don't think that we need to i think we
should be respectful of people
but i don't think we should be
respectful of bad ideas i think this
gnostic idea that my
my body has nothing to do with my actual
identity
is ridiculous and we should ignore it
and we should say it's not true and not
teach it
because when you put these things on
equal ground you
empower very bad ideas and when you
empower these bad ideas
they tend not to be happy to leave it at
just a sort of nice liberal tolerance
they want to dominate
because ideologies make truth claims
right they say this is the way the world
is and
anything that does not jive with that
they're going to try to get rid of so
this guy gives his his talk the trent
college here the allegedly christian
college invites a group called
educate and celebrate to make their
school more
quote lgbt friendly educate and
celebrate this non-profit
declare that the school's mission is to
embed gender gender identity and sexual
orientation into the fabric of your
school
so if you do this if you are a christian
school and you invite
this group educate and celebrate what an
orwellian bizarre creepy vague name
if you invite them to your school
they're going to embed gender ideology
in your school and
what that is going what that decision
amounts to is
de-christianizing your school you used
to have a christian school
now you have a gender ideology school
okay that's just
you're going to make that decision as
the president of the school that's what
you're going to get
the head of the charity dr ellie barnes
says that the purpose of educate and
celebrate is to quote
completely smash heteronormativity
that's what we want to do so that's it
the christian school invites in this
radical group
to destroy the christian vision of the
school
fair enough that's the school if they
want to do it
you know the problem here is also that
the church of england has just
completely cracked up over the last 50
years or so
i i once had a former anglican
who became a catholic tell me that to
join the church of england now
and to to become ordained in the church
of england is not just to rearrange the
deck chairs on the titanic it's to
actually grab and hold on as the thing
goes all the way down to the bottom
and so this poor guy reverend dr bernard
randall
is asks this question
he says or rather he makes this point he
says when ideologies compete we should
respect everybody okay
but one should no more be required
to accept lgbt ideology then you should
be
told that you're in favor of brexit or
that you must be muslim
we would object to that right i i made
this point i think on the show yesterday
i made this point somewhere
i don't know you may have heard it
somewhere which is
if a muslim comes out and quotes the
quran
then a homosexual or transvestite
might rightly object that they are being
victimized on the basis of their
sexual orientation or gender identity
right because
the quran has strong things to say
about those sorts of identities and
behaviors but
if the transvestite
criticizes the muslim for quoting the
qur'an then the muslim
could complain on the basis of being
victimized for his
religion you've got these competing
ideologies here
and which which do we give
the the greater latitude toward that's
the question that people are grappling
with right now and it would appear that
the
the answer is on the radical sex front
because
what what happened to this guy's he
didn't just get fired but he
ends up being reported to a terror watch
list that is aimed at protecting youth
against radicalization
so right now
apply to the american context drag queen
story hour you know you've got
you've got radical gender ideologues
indoctrinating
your toddlers into how to twerk and how
to make little boys look like little
girls
that is considered mainstream in the
culture
christianity is considered radical and
there are now government programs in the
united kingdom
to watch out for this sort of thing he
ultimately was not
permanently listed as a terrorist but he
was reported it shows you
where the perception is among the people
there
this is happening in america it's coming
to america mike pompeo former secretary
of state
just addressed this at regent university
today i want to speak to you about the
challenges that are ahead
of you as followers of christ
and who you should approach them and
overcome them our freedoms
particularly our unalienable right of
religious freedom
is increasingly under attack from our
government be it local state
or federal more and more
more and more being a good follower of
christ is becoming less synonymous with
being a good american
even though you know the history the
founding of our country is deeply rooted
in judeo-christian values
it gives new meaning to the theme i was
asked to address
in philippians 4 13 that says i can do
all things through christ
who strengthens me each of you
each of you can meet those challenges
but you'll not be able to overcome them
without christ
there's not a chance i love this i
really love this speech
i'm very glad that secretary pompeo gave
it
now you notice some tensions here
because he opens up when he opened up
the speech i thought okay this will be
perfectly fine speech but it's not going
to be
it's not going to knock every anybody
off their feet because he opened up on
the issue of religious liberty
not on what we believe but just on the
freedom to believe stuff
and as i lay out in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
freedom of belief doesn't mean anything
for people who don't believe anything
freedom of speech in the abstract
doesn't mean anything for people who
don't have anything to say
so the question is what do we believe so
he opens up on it we have this
freedom of belief freedom of religion
but then he implies he doesn't say it
explicitly but he implies that freedom
of religion
has limits because then he says
less and less each day do we seem to
hold to this idea that being a good
christian
is synonymous with being a good american
wow
what an insight in in for the vast
majority of our country's history
it was a christian country it was
founded as a christian country
i know that some people take a line out
of context from the treaty of tripoli
when some american diplomats were trying
to convince muslim pirates not to
capture and sell our sailors into
bondage but uh
if you take that ridiculous line out for
just a second and you look at the actual
writings of the actual founding fathers
and the men who led the country
it's quite clear this is a christian
country they always when they point to
the treaty of tripoli they say john
adams said that america
is not in any way founded on the
christian nation you say first of all
john adams didn't write the treaty of
tripoli
he affixed his name to it i suppose it
was actually written by jeffersonian
republican
but uh but even beyond that jefferson
said that the morality of america is the
morality of christianity that's it
he wrote about it at greater length
elsewhere so anyway you you can read the
full arguments for that in my
in my upcoming books speechless
controllers controlling minds but
does that count as two i guess it does i
figured it was an extended plug but
that's fine i'll take two dings
he says um america always considered
itself a christian country that's what
he's implying and but now less and less
so each day
so okay if america always
seemed to consider itself a christian
country if being a good christian was
synonymous with being a good american
then that means that there wasn't total
total religious freedom
in the most radical sense you didn't
have freedom exactly from religion
i'll put it more bluntly
in the declaration of independence the
the premise of the american revolution
is that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and that they're endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
and among these are life liberty and
pursuit of happiness
if our country is predicated on the on
the idea
that we are endowed by our creator with
certain rights
this very christian idea
then one does not have the liberty
to contradict that idea and to be an
american that would be incoherent
when does one does not have the thought
or rather as chesterton says there's a
thought that stops thought that's the
only thought that ought to be stopped
one does not have the right
to the thought that stops thought it is
it is incoherent to say i am an american
and i totally undermine and i totally
dispute all of the things that make
america america
you can't have that and still have a
country
john locke very famously in the letter
concerning toleration as the father of
liberalism says we need to tolerate
everybody except for atheists
which is where you get this idea that
yeah you have quite
quite a lot of latitude with in terms of
your freedom of religion but you do not
have
freedom from religion and by the way i'm
not even making a prescriptive statement
here i'm not even saying we need to be
really tough on atheists
i'm just making a descriptive
observation
everybody's got to serve somebody
everybody's got some religion
the woke people have a more rigid
and fanatical religion than anybody in
this country right now
they're just not even aware of it most
of the time and that religion
is a jealous god and it makes claims
they're booting out true religion
in this milieu and this craziness and
this madness
an msnbc guest goes on tv and compares
the republican party
to al qaeda the majority of people in
this party and their elected leadership
is siding with the anti-democratic
forces within the republican party
it's not that it's just a segment of the
party it's not becoming the entire party
i don't think there are enough
of people who are willing to stand up to
this iteration of the republican party
to build another party at this point i
mean for all of the conversation about
liz cheney or or mitt romney or adam
kindergarten they're the outliers
and it's really it's really something
hearing those comments from president
george w bush i've been thinking to
myself this whole time
you know al qaeda osama bin laden
the taliban the people who wanted to do
harm to our nation
and to our way of life in our democracy
they got nothing
on what this republican party is doing
the idea
that a member of their party of their
leadership whose last name is cheney
could be purged from their leadership
for telling the truth about january 6
for telling the truth about a violent
insurrection that claimed the lies
of among a capital police officer
the republican party according to this
msnbc guy
is far more uh
of a threat to the america that he
envisions
than al-qaeda al-qaeda
ain't got nothing on these guys he says
obviously
an outrageous and inflammatory statement
but i'm and this guy doesn't know
anything about anything he's pulling the
same the usual tactic of
i you know look i love liz cheney i love
george w bush they're all the
republicans that lose and hate the
republican party and
are now attacking the party and
supporting the democrats i really
support them i have a strange new
respect for them so he's pulling that
thing whatever it's a sort of
stupid political rhetorical device but
people use it on his point though
i want to give it the most charitable
read possible
i think he's actually has a little bit
of a point
this msnbc guy
believes that the republican party
is has is far more transformative
for the uh country than al qaeda or
osama bin laden or something like that
he's absolutely right in this sense
what did osama bin laden and the taliban
and the people who
launched the attacks on 9 11 do they
killed thousands of innocent americans
this was this was the worst
bloodiest most terrible attack in
american history
yes
it did not succeed at what it attempted
succeeded in killing people but it did
not succeed at the ideological goal of
totally changing the direction of the
country
actually what happened is we just kind
of kept up the same policies that we
already had we ratcheted them up a
little bit but the the liberal
internationalism
uh that we saw with george h.w bush and
that you saw
to a lesser degree with bill clinton and
you see with george w bush and you see
it with
with obama that just kind of continued
to pace
in fact we restarted a war that we had
already won
in the early 90s we actually just went
right back to what we were doing before
whereas this republican party that msnbc
has such a big problem with
this republican party is
threatening that liberal establishment
the liberal establishment that actually
goes back further than george h.w bush
you see the kind of seeds of this
progressivism
uh in the during the cold war certainly
after world war ii
and on the domestic front even going
back further than that and franklin
roosevelt and even all the way back to
woodrow wilson
this republican party right now is
questioning that
is actually threatening that was there
really much of a difference between bill
clinton and george w bush and george h.w
bush and barack obama
there wasn't a huge difference what
there was
was a you know a little change on the
margins
but then trump comes in and he says
actually all you guys are wrong on
foreign policy
all of you all of the same foreign
policy and you're all wrong all you guys
are wrong on trade
you all have basically the same trade
regime and it's totally wrong
all you guys are wrong on manufacturing
you're outsourcing that's totally wrong
all you guys are wrong on immigration on
some of the most important
issues you guys are totally wrong
so
because of this the left you know
they'll say nice things about george
bush or liz cheney right now
because the real threat to them the real
threat to their vision of the country
are all those trumpy type of republicans
the msnbc guy is using outrageous
disgusting inflammatory rhetoric but the
point he's making i think is actually
pretty fair
joe biden is the most radical president
in american history i'm not being
hyperbolic when i say that actually
associates of the president say the same
thing new york magazine
just covered this so new york magazine a
liberal outlet quoting a liberal person
who is close to joe biden says sometimes
dumb tactics yield
desired outcomes in march the associated
press distributed a memo advising
reporters to avoid or use caution
when using the word crisis only one very
real possibility is
that one one very real possibility is
this strategy works the person close to
the white house added
they may get criticism and think pieces
about it but at his hundred day mark
biden is the most liberal president
we've had and the public thinks he's a
moderate that's a winning strategy to me
they're willing to accept that you're
going to write this piece as long as
they know
that swing voters in colorado aren't
going to read it wow what a great
insight
what a fabulous insight here and this is
something that ted cruz pointed out
a long time ago on our show verdict
which is that
joe biden talks like good old uncle joe
and he's very
kind of lulls you to sleep and he talks
about scranton
taking the amtrak but because he doesn't
believe anything because he wakes up in
the morning licks his finger puts it in
the air
figures out which way the wind is
blowing joe biden
is uh he's just a weather vane so he'll
if the party's moving very far to the
left then he's going to move very far
to the left as well but he's not he's
not going to worry people i think of
you know plenty of senior citizens right
who don't want all this crazy
craziness going on right now in our
culture they remember joe biden and they
said
i like joe i know joe's fine and so even
says yeah okay you put this in new york
magazine
those rural voters in colorado they
don't care they're not going to be
reading new york magazine
radical radical stuff so what is the gop
going to do about it
the gop right now is facing an identity
crisis
they've got leadership that does not
represent them you've got liz cheney
who's basically just a
liberal internationalist of the kind of
bush era
but you know at this point now she's
siding much more with the democrats than
with the republicans at least as a
matter of
jockeying for party power she might vote
with the republicans on some more issues
but in terms of who's controlling things
she's
siding with the democrats so finally
after they defended this woman
a month or two ago finally the house
leader
mccarthy is coming out against her he
says just as we serve at the will of our
constituents
this leadership team should exist to
serve you not the other way around it
had been my hope that our driving focus
would be taking back the house in 2022
and implementing our commitment to
america despite the mainstream media
working overtime against us
i believe we still have a great chance
to do so unfortunately each day
spent relitigating the past is one day
less we have to seize the future
this is no time to take our eye off the
ball if we are to succeed in stopping
the radical democrat agenda from
destroying our country
these internal conflicts need to be
resolved so as to
not detract from the efforts of our
collective team having heard from so
many of you in recent days
it's clear that we need to make a change
as such you should anticipate a vote on
recalling the conference chair this
wednesday good glad to hear it great
stuff now unfortunately they want to
replace her with elise stefanik
who is this more liberal member of the
gop that's no
we don't we don't support that but we do
like that at least the gop is getting
serious about
taking out people who who do not support
the party so what kind of republicans
should we be looking at
well here are the types obviously this
guy's not in the house of
representatives but here are the types
republican wyoming governor mark gordon
who just on friday issued a directive
to block state agencies from
establishing the use of vaccine
passports
which some states are soon going to
require for residents very good it
doesn't go far enough
as far as i can tell this doesn't ban
private businesses from requiring them
the government should go in this is a
good use of government power the
government needs to go in
and ban businesses add more regulation
to grow the size and scope of the
government to ban businesses
from forcing people to show the stupid
vaccine passport
when they go to try to get a beer at the
pub ron desantis
has done an excellent job at this in
florida ron desantis is kind of the
leader among the republican governors
to contrast with that you have the
excelsior pass in new york
which will use secure technology yeah
because we've seen how secure the
technology is
we've seen how the big tech overlords
they totally have our best interests at
heart
to prove that a state resident has been
vaccinated against covid19 now this also
gives the option
to show they've had a negative test but
obviously the push here
is for the vaccines
one in five americans do not want to get
the vaccine
one in five americans don't want to get
the vaccine now initial estimates for
herd immunity
against covet 19 according to reports
were to set that number around 40 to 50
percent
dr fauci now says that immunization has
to be over 80 percent
but one in five americans according to a
recent survey from the economist in
yougov
don't want to get the vaccine
nearly 70 percent said they're cool that
18 said they won't be getting the shots
and of the people who aren't getting
aren't getting the shots when asked if
they could be persuaded to get the
vaccine 79
said no i totally get it i totally get
why not
i guess i guess the category that i'm in
is i don't intend to get the vaccine
could i be persuaded i guess so i've got
an open mind
but i i don't intend to get it and if
we're
already going to get 80 then it sounds
like we're good
doesn't it and if the public health
officials
have squandered all of their credibility
then
i guess there's no reason to pay any
attention to them
i i get look i get we need experts we
need the doctors to tell us about i get
i'm not even against vaccines generally
but if people have squandered their
credibility if they have misled on
multiple occasions if the things that
they have predicted have not come true
then it's going to raise a question in
people's minds and you're going to hear
for quite a while now you're going to
hear people say
that this 80 you know that this 20
rather that don't want to get vaccinated
they're terrible they're stupid they're
anti-vaxxers they're
dumb they're endangering the public
health those people
have every reason every justification
to be very skeptical of these public
health experts
who by the way even by these numbers
will achieve
the degree of immunity that they set out
to achieve and by the early estimates
they're actually going to get
more immunity than that so why the push
why the push for the vaccine passports
and the insistence and the shaming
and the ostracism it is about the
imposition
of this political will and if we want to
fight back it's not enough even just to
have the ideas floating around in our
heads
we have to enact it we have to push for
it we have to offer a substantive vision
of politics and then have the courage
to actually enforce that and not just
say you do you whatever you want to
actually enforce
our vision of politics lest we all
become like gamora by the sea
unless we all go like california and all
go down together hope we don't i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nica geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show hamas
fires hundreds of rockets into israel
while the squad rushes to defend them
president biden inherits middle east
peace and instead fomen's middle east
war
and the 1970s gas lines are back baby
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen